bonjour et bienvenue sur nos sept captv
dans ce cadre exceptionnel qui est le
théâtre plein air de saint-gilles
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
d'artistes est précisément de musiciens
qui vont faire vivre le festival total
jazz rencontre jean-pierre valu d'avoir
donc jean-pierre tous des fines
arrangeur compositeur passionné de jazz
guitariste et leader de la fondation
josé fille aux phrases ou jean pierre
diaz pour toi c'est quelque chose qui a
commencé très jeune ans réjeanne au
niveau des oreilles notamment par
rapport à mon frère et écoutent beaucoup
mais le jazz un petit peu plus ce jeu là
c'est quand l'enfant de la duke
ellington count basie lionel hampton et
ses terrains et apprécié
dans le même temps matt écoute beaucoup
aussi un petit peu plus fusionner
notamment un gala marquant même et
toujours actuel pour tu vas de qualité
c'est de la lca gagne ça c'est vraiment
génial toujours d'actualité et forcément
on est tous les la pop les années 70 80
adp in jeff beck
c'est en éclats aussi aussi pop du rock
complètement alors jean-pierre donc
c'est toi qui a fait l'ouverture du
festival
totalgaz ici à saint gilles ça
représente quoi pour toi de base
ouvrière c'est plusieurs jours dédiés le
site du théâtre en plein air c'est un
site fabuleux parce que c'est la musique
sur les étoiles c'est une consécration
par rapport à ce projet et par rapport
aux 6,1 ma carrière d'artiste de rejouer
petit nico 700 entreprises sur
différents projets donc
j'avais origines australes menée en
septembre et octobre 2013 au festival
international de sanaa manager car après
deux ans et demi leur sortie l'album est
maintenant on est programmé pour en
faire une ouverture du festival nous un
total jazz mx1
comment on peut qualifier un peu novice
faire ton style de musique / rapport au
jazz c'est parce que forcément il ya des
influences locales des mac séance de la
musique traditionnelle créole de tia le
maloya
tout ça ça se fait aussi une touche
particulière un style propre
on va dire un d'information voilà
complètement depuis mon premier album
maskemane de voler dans cette lignée
cette optique sa direction cette ses
compositions mais sur les compositeurs
arrangeurs et
et forcément on y peut parler s'est
affirmé également par rapport à mes
racines que c'est maloya séga l'océan
indien puisque me notamment dans ce sens
gêné basse avec madagascar
il bosse avec le mozambique et l'afrique
du sud et au niveau historique nous les
complètement liés malgré la distance
donc c'est une grande force de jouer les
tracés tradition là avec le jazz dont le
poids le total général maire fait le rsa
polonais l'étiquette mollard les
étiquettes
l'appel sera jazz world sinon ça peut
être aussi du world jazz selon les
festivaliers mais complètement là dedans
être qu' il ya un moment particulier des
changes est un peu fort avec d'autres
médias c'est près de paris
quand même une musique qui arrivent pas
beaucoup d'événements beaucoup de
festivals ou place en est un à la
réunion du versant le plus important et
voilà il ya des ambiances des
atmosphères il ya quelque chose de
particulier sur ce festival
total doit forcément passer n'a beaucoup
de manières de connaisseurs mais en même
temps il ya beaucoup de curieux et sur
le projet
et en général sur les projets avant mais
sur ce projet encore plus jamais ça
compte vraiment où les tuniques sans
exception parce que les gens rient
retrouvé de note un petit peu dans dans
la musique les rites puisque et c'est
vraiment très ouvert très accessible pas
un intellectuel comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
ça demande une certaine connaissance et
l'expérience cette année coûte mais là
ça reste accessible en tirant toujours
pas en par le haut puisque les gardois
sectionné cd gratry très pointu camp
là on revient du capital international
jazz festival où sont les plus grands
festivals de reading en termes de jazz
le jazz world etc et on a joué sur la
plus grande scène
donc on a représenté fièrement la
réunion car c'était vraiment super un
super festival on va parler aussi de
l'album puisque l'album il sera clair
s'est récemment qu'ils s'appellent ben
ça donne ça c'est un mot que j'ai
inventé
un petit peu espagnol portugais d'une
salle annonce et trappes qu'à attraper
catch denz et attraper la danse m'a fait
les frais
la majorité des compositions avec une
composition d
si l'africa mozambicaine malgache pourra
porter nos couleurs
malheureusement voilà pour ceux qui sont
intéressés donc ils prendront l'album
sinon débat qui viennent de tout ce qui
va le total jazz sur la scène du père
peinard ne s'inquiète donc rendez vous
le jeudi 21 avril à 19h30 avec les
embarquer